do you anticipate do you worry about
pressures from outside sources from
society from politicians from money
sources I both worry about it and want
it like you know to the point of wearing
this bubble and we shouldn't make all
these decisions like we want Society to
have a huge degree of input here that is
pressure in some point in some way well
there's a you know that's what like uh
to some degree
uh Twitter files have revealed that
there was uh pressure from different
organizations you can see in the
pandemic where the CDC or some other
government organization might put
pressure on you know what uh we're not
really sure what's true but it's very
unsafe to have these kinds of nuanced
conversations now so let's censor all
topics so you get a lot of those emails
like you know
um emails all different kinds of people
reaching out at different places to put
subtle indirect pressure direct pressure
Financial political pressure all that
kind of stuff like how do you survive
that
how much do you worry about that
if GPD continues to get more and more
intelligent and the source of
information and knowledge for human
civilization
I think there's like a lot of like
quirks about me that make me
not a great CEO for open AI but a thing
in the positive column
is I think I am
relatively
good at
not being affected by pressure for the
sake of pressure
by the way beautiful statement of
humility but I have to ask what's what's
in the negative column oh I mean
too long a list
what's a good one
I mean I think I'm not a great like
spokesperson for the AI movement I'll
say that I think there could be like a
more like
there could be someone who enjoyed it
more there could be someone who's like
much more charismatic there could be
someone who like connects better I think
with people than I I do I'm with shelves
again this I think Charisma is a
dangerous thing I think I think uh flaws
in
flaws and communication style I think is
a feature not a bug in general at least
for humans at least for humans in power
I think I have like more serious
problems than that one um
I think I'm like
pretty
disconnected from like the reality of
life for most people
and trying to really not just like
empathize with but internalize what the
impact on people that AGI is going to
have
I probably like feel that less than
other people would
that's really well put and you said like
you're going to travel across the world
to yeah I'm excited to empathize with
different users not an empathize just to
like
I want to just like buy our users our
developers our users a drink and say
like tell us what you'd like to change
and I think one of the things we are not
good as good as a company as I would
like is to be a really user-centric
company
and I feel like by the time it gets
filtered to me it's like totally
meaningless so I really just want to go
talk to a lot of our users in very
different contexts but like you said a
drink in person because
but I haven't actually found the right
words for it but I I was I was a little
afraid with the programming
emotionally I I don't think it makes any
sense there is a real Olympic response
there GPT makes me nervous about the
future not in an AI safety way but like
change yeah change
and like there's a nervousness about
changing more nervous than excited
if I take away the fact that I'm an AI
person and just a programmer more
excited but still nervous like yeah
nervous in brief moments especially when
sleep deprived but there's a nervousness
there people who say they're not nervous
I I it's hard for me to believe
the URI is excited it's nervous for
change nervous whenever there's
significant exciting kind of change
um you know I've recently started using
um I've been an emacs person for a very
long time and I switched to vs code
as a more co-pilot uh that was one of
the big cool reasons because like this
is where a lot of active development of
course you could probably do uh copilot
inside
um emacs I mean I'm sure she has code is
also pretty good yeah there's a lot of
like little little things and and big
things that are just really good about
vs codes and I've been I can happily
report in all the event people are just
going nuts but I'm very happy it's a
very happy decision but there was a lot
of uncertainty there's a lot of
nervousness about it there's fear and so
on
um
about taking that leap and that's
obviously a tiny leap but even just the
leap to actively using co-pilot like
using a generation of code it makes you
nervous but ultimately your my life is
much better as a programmer purely as a
programmering a programmer of little
things and big things is much better but
there's a nervousness and I think a lot
of people will experience that
experience that and you will experience
that by talking to them and I don't know
what we do with that
um
how we Comfort people in in the in the
face of this uncertainty and you're
getting more nervous the more you use it
not less
yes I would have to say yes because I
get better at using it so the learning
curve is quite steep yeah
and then there's moments when you're
like oh it generates a function
beautifully
and you sit back both proud like a
parent
but almost like proud like and scared
that this thing will be much smarter
than me like both pride and uh sadness
almost like a Melancholy feeling but
ultimately Joy I think yeah